where are we practicing today daddy yeah
where are we practicing today well we
going someplace special today
these houses are huge yes that one looks
like a castle you all like these others
yes so that looks like the white house
which one which one you like what's your
favorite
i like that one
yeah that one's nice if that was my
house i'd put a pool in the front and a
slide on the roof don't put your crew in
there everybody's gonna want to come to
my house oh you're just gonna be the
crazy lady on the block i'm gonna be the
coolest person on the block that one has
a tennis court oh that's the one there
that's the one
you're gonna have any one of these
houses you want
beverly hills hollywood hills any of
these old hills
because you got a plan and you're going
to stick to it
i was a little boy my mom's used to
saying son
the most strongest the most powerful the
most dangerous creature on this whole
earth
it's a woman who know how to think
ain't nothing she can't do
you all know how to think
yes daddy now these people we about to
go see you gonna show em how dangerous
you are yes you got it let me see your
dangerous face
that's your dangerous face
that's your dangerous face that's okay
don't do that for the people
this is a movie about the number one and
number two tennis players of all time
[Music]
two years before the girls were born
richard wrote out plans for their entire
careers
ian orsine taught themselves tennis
before venus was born they were learning
as a family
you know i was like wait that can't be
true you wouldn't believe this story
everything was about
family
belief
love
and triumph
this is a feel-good movie that you would
watch every thanksgiving
[Music]
i absolutely had to tell this story
growing up in compton it was incredibly
hard mom working double shifts to put
food on the table
richard had many jobs all of the sisters
were on the courts with them they would
pick up balls they would hang signs
we got future doctors and lawyers plus a
couple tennis stars in this house
the chance of success is very unlikely
you making a mistake but i'ma let you
make it
we all have impossible dreams sometimes
our circumstances may not necessarily
line up to that
but that strength of the human spirit
to overpower circumstances like venus
and serena is wish fulfillment for all
of us
[Music]
like that
i think you might just have the next
michael jordan oh no brother man i got
me the next two
[Music]
do you know how
there you go
[Music]
i know you love venus
and all this is exciting but
it's a little hard for you too huh
can i tell you a secret
your sister
is gonna be number one in the whole
world no doubt about it
i know
that but you
you're gonna be the best it ever was
you're gonna be the greatest of all time
you know how i know
because i plan for it
[Music]
i'm gonna take that in
you up next
[Music]
you